[Music]
my name is Ralph Helmick and I'm a
sculptor I was asked there was some way
to create an artwork that could help
guide a visitor from the street level up
to the third floor main entrance to the
Institute what's behind me is what we
ended up with 100 gold leaf unique
sculptures of neurons they're made out
of a matrix of stainless steel and
bronze and they range in size from over
3 feet long to about 12 inches tip to
tip and suspended very very precisely I
came up with five different cell bodies
different kinds of dendritic forms and
so I made kits of parts of different
sizes that I could then customize and
assemble and I developed these forms in
consultation with people at the lab I
[Music]
chose gold leafing because it catches
light so beautifully and one of the
experimenters here they said they
actually used gold and one line of
inquiry and neuroscience the title of
this piece is fair plunked and that's a
German word one of the definitions of
which is focal point when one views it
from a sweet spot that is just as one's
about to enter the main office of the
McGovern Institute one can look down
toward the entry and all of these
hundred neurons optically collapse into
a graphic image of a brain hemisphere
that optical phenomenon is called an
amorphous I think in Greek that
translates to re formation or
re-creation for me this is a metaphor
for the discovery that goes on in the
building maybe a metaphor for the
elegant design of many of the
experiments that are taking place here
[Music]
what they do here is so profound on a
practical level and maybe in a way that
art is not practical I hope that the
fairphone could recall or evoke that
sense of discovery I think as a culture
we're hungry for surprise we're hungry
for optical phenomena or we're hungry
for a positive experience that's what
I'm trying to do here is something that
elevates us and I think every researcher
in this building is doing research that
seeks to elevate our culture
[Music]
[Music]